this is Moldova's first and so far only
National Park with villagers fields and
60% forest the environment takes
priority here above the interests of
people elsewhere in the Republic things
are different about 3/4 of Moldova's
land is under cultivation and pesticides
and artificial fertilizers are widely
used monocultures of corn and sunflowers
have resulted in leached soil and
chemical contamination the oil guru has
set out to change that he's the
president of pro rural invest an NGO
that promotes organic farming and
produce in ten years EF we will say that
20% of agricultural land in Moldova is
under organic agriculture it will be
great these berries were grown
organically aronia or chokeberries they
taste sour but is said to possess
healing properties it's a health food
that helps I see great potential for it
potential and just produce pro rural
invest awarded this farmer it's organic
seal it has no official status in the
European Union but it still seems to
have attracted customers from the Czech
Republic where demand for natural
produce is steadily growing guru is off
again this time to check on one of his
success stories the mana coal company
during harvest seasons over 300 people
work for mana coal the company exports
nuts and prunes more and more of them
grown organically CEO Demetriou vehicle
says over 90% of his exports go to the
European Union because of our old
improvements in the processing and the
harvesting we are convincing now that
our products can compete with other
products from around the world Eco video
is a Moldovan grassroots environmental
NGO it's holding an organic filing
workshop president Valerius part Kroger
is hoping to effect a change in her
society's values actually more and more
people start understanding so the
environmental awareness is growing in
our country I feel
is a perfect time now to really put the
efforts on the highest level of
intensity to make opportunities visible
organic agriculture means greater
diversity in stark contrast to
monoculture